this is Georgetown the Catholic Guyana
a tiny South American country that sits
right on the edge of that mighty Amazon
jungle located on the northern edge of
South America this english-speaking
nation is made up of thousands of square
miles of untamed rivers and dense
rainforests I'm starting my journey on
the coast in the capital city of
Georgetown which boasts an exciting
fusion of Caribbean Indian and European
cultures now I'm here to make super
talented gathering chef
velvet Adams who's responsible for
putting this somewhat unknown cuisine on
the culinary map thanks buzz Chrissy way
take care right this is the market where
a Delvin welcome to my country absolute
pleasure chef Kelvin Adams is determined
to introduce Guyanese cuisine to the
world after honing his culinary skills
in the remote jungle cooking for oil
drillers he returned to his home in
Georgetown to open the backyard cafe a
hot spot that celebrates his country's
exciting one-of-a-kind dishes when you
think about how small the reputation of
goin these cuisine is on the culinary
map right yeah I'm hoping to find this
sort of the DNA of that well you're
gonna get dead yeah so I'm gonna show
you the market area show you how I do it
Diana's warm and tropical climates is
year-round growing an incredible variety
of produce everything from your garden
standards those cherry tomatoes yeah
beautiful Chinese long beans every
household is gonna use this every day to
hottia root vegetables one of which
forms this starchy basis for much of the
country's cuisine cassava this right
here is the the essence of what gann is
all about it serves like a root
vegetable it's a root vegetable we got
some cash up here too very unique
product made from the bitter cassava not
the sweet cassava and the bit excessive
ax has Sinai in it and this is why you
wouldn't see that selling on the
marketplace I can take a heart elephants
now unless processed properly to remove
the cyanide poison bitter cassava can
kill
and you're finishing that inside that
you've finished this in our Pepperpot
which is a national dish of always
Pepperpot is a meat stew
created by guy honors native Amerindian
people and I'm excited to try it and
would it be like a chicken pepper pot
lamb no well this here is a lubber
pepper pot lover so we're talking like a
one-ball like a noir Pig
no this is a big rodent are you saying
useful rat it's a big rodent Wow good
stuff weighing up to 26 pounds l'abbé is
a dog sized mammal that lives in the
Guyanese jungles it's meat is that
prized delicacy it's actually quite nice
yeah it tastes this sort of almost like
a little suckling pig
it's actually very sweet so could you do
this with a chicken or a pork does it
have to be rodent doesn't have to be
rolling you could do this with chicken
pork is our pride and joy right here
harass this no not the rat the pepper
pot the pepper pot pepper pot and the
kazran that was good by the way really
indeed a nice little start of a you know
an inside to this guy knees cruising so
with all of this that I've shown you yes
deep rooted with our Amerindian people
right the Armenians are our first people
and we take pride and joy in our first
people right
Delvin explains that the origins of
Guyanese cooking lie with the Amerindian
people and my mission is to head to the
jungle village everyone to spend a week
immersing myself in their culture you're
gonna get on a plane you get in the
jungle hunt fish and you can learn their
ways and hopefully you'll learn a whole
lot from them at the end of the week
Delvin and i will cook for the tribes
chief who will decide whether i'd come
to grips with the cuisine that's existed
for thousands of years
right no pressure no pressure failure is
not an option
see you in the way but see you buddy
thank you yep wanna see more for my
uncharted adventures please click here
to watch more clips